Speaker 1: Today we're going to be speaking
with Bill Keller, who was the founding editor
in chief of the Marshall Project and also
author of the book What's Prison for Punishment
and Rehabilitation in the Age of Mass Incarceration.
Bill, I really appreciate you being on today.
Speaker 5: Thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, I guess to start with,
at least in some theoretical sense, prison
sentences in the United States are supposed
to be for rehabilitation.
Right.
The idea that someone has done something wrong,
harmful to society and or to victims, they
have been sentenced to some amount of time
in prison.
And that that experience, the time that they
spend in prison is at least to some degree,
rehabilitative, in addition to being punitive,
so that when they serve their sentence, they
come out and now they're rehabilitated.
Right.
I mean, at least sort of theoretically.
Can you talk about whether in practice any
elements of the criminal justice system in
the U.S. actually function in that way?
Speaker 5: Not really.
I mean, you can find individual programs that
function that way.
Some of them are experimental, some of them
more broadly based, like college education
programs that actually do rehabilitate.
But there's there are a number of obstacles.
One of them is cost.
It's expensive to do rehabilitation programs.
You know, you need trained personnel and so
on.
One of them is puritanical streak, I think,
in American culture.
The main objective from that point of view
and rehabilitation is just pampering.
Also, prisons are not the most ideal therapeutic
environment.
They're scary, they're noisy that people will
leave.
Some are really cops, not therapists or social
workers.
They don't have the training to administer
those sorts of programs.
So there are a lot of obstacles.
The heroes of my book, if I can call them
that, are the.
The corrections officials are trying to improve
rehabilitation in spite of the obstacles and
the teachers, the volunteers, the.
Kind of a mystery why I chose to write about
write about prisons rather than courts or
cops because.
There's been a lot of attention, deservedly
paid, to policing judges and prosecutors,
for the most part run for public office and
do a lot of their business in public.
Prisons are kind of a mystery.
So that's that's why I wanted to focus on
that.
Speaker 1: If we put aside for a second when
there are actual rehabilitative rehabilitation
programs, the sort of status quo day to day
of being in your standard prison at this point,
we know beyond any doubt that's not a rehabilitative
experience in any way, is it?
And in fact, that it could sort of be the
opposite.
Speaker 5: Now we write there's considerable
research by people like Bruce Western at Columbia
who show that being incarcerated can actually
make you more likely to commit crimes when
you get out.
Right.
Speaker 1: And when we when we say that, I
mean, there's this sort of general idea.
Prison can turn you into it, turn you into
a more hardened or violent criminal.
And it's often repeated.
But what sort of what sort of data do we have
about that?
Speaker 5: Well, the one piece of data that's
kind of shocking is that.
Two thirds of the people who are incarcerated
will be re-arrested within five years of their
release.
The recidivism rate is a tricky metric, and
then people measure it different ways.
But recidivism suggests that we are not doing
a very effective job of rehabilitating overall.
Speaker 1: When we talk about the deterrent
effect of the system that we have and the
idea that at the end of some crime that one
commits, if you are caught and charged and
convicted, there could be a punishment.
That's coming from what I've read.
Studies have found that the death penalty,
as compared to life in prison without parole,
does not seem to be a functional deterrent
in terms of reducing the crimes wherein one
would be eligible for such punishments.
What do we know more generally about prison
sentences and the deterrent effect on those
not in prison?
Speaker 5: There's a sociologist named Francis
Cullen at University of Cincinnati who's done
a lot of work on this subject.
And he he makes this logical argument that
the deterrent effect assumes that before you
commit a crime, you stop and consider the
risks in a sort of logical way.
Whereas the great majority of crimes are either
opportunistic that are done in concert with,
you know, going along with a gang.
They're spontaneous.
And to the extent that people do stop and
consider the consequences before they do something
illegal, then they're mainly considering the
chances of getting caught.
Right.
It doesn't make a difference to them whether
the judgment is five years for a felony or
20 years for a felony.
But that's just not the way people think.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
You know, we were talking about jaywalking
yesterday on our program because the California
Governor Newsom recently signed into law a
bill that that mostly decriminalized this
jaywalking.
And I think that there's sort of some gray
area in the sense that, like, you know, I
jaywalk all the time.
And it is true that if I knew that life in
prison was a possible sentence for jaywalking,
I wouldn't do it.
But you need these really extreme examples
that that in order to really be able to make
that case.
Whereas as you talk about with many crimes,
murder in particular, murders are are such
a type of crime.
We're already you're talking about only a
fraction of the population is even willing
to commit a murder.
Based on the research we have that the line
between life in prison with no parole and
death penalty, for example, it seems like
it's a completely different type of consideration
than my jaywalking example.
Speaker 5: Right.
I mean, I would never say that that the risk
of going to jail or being severely punished
doesn't figure into anybody's thinking at
all.
And the deterrent exists, but it's just greatly
exaggerated when you weigh that against the
the effects of being incarcerated on commit
another crime.
It's not it's not a convincing reason to lock
people up, especially to lock people up as
we do for far longer periods of time and for
lesser crimes than most other countries.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I want to talk about that
next.
So can you give some specific examples of
average sentence in the U.S. for certain crimes
compared to in some other countries for which
we have data for the same crime?
Speaker 5: Sure.
Sorry.
I just lost my train of thought.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Any crime that you.
That we could think of a difference in average
sentencing between the U.S. and other countries?
Speaker 5: Oh, I know.
What I was going to say is mass incarceration
is a relatively new phenomenon for us.
I think that's important to remember that
for most of the 20th century.
The incarceration rate in the United States
was something like 100 people incarcerated
for every 100,000 population, which was a
little higher than the rest of the world,
but not not off the tracks.
And then beginning in the seventies, we took
a sharp right turn.
And it became more like 500.
People over 100,000, the population.
I mean, that's an incredible phenomenon.
And part of that is.
That we incarcerate people for much longer
periods of time most.
I'm talking here about developed countries,
mostly the European countries, the ones that
I take a look at.
Most countries don't have a death penalty.
They don't have life without parole.
And.
Look, I talk about the case of Anders Breivik,
the Norwegian mass murderer who slaughtered
70 some kids at a party political party picnic.
And instead of 21 years now, it is deemed
to be a danger to society.
A judge can extend that.
But that's that's a severe plus to maximum
punishment.
Right.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Are there you know, sometimes there's this
idea that if you do the European style of
incarceration where conditions generally speaking
are better and sentences are shorter, that
there is a higher recidivism rate.
But it doesn't appear to be borne out in the
data, is it?
Speaker 5: No.
The recidivism rates in all of the Scandinavian
countries and Germany and most of the developed
world are considerably lower than ours.
Speaker 1: So to me, what that says is that
for some of the folks in the United States
who are demanding the stricter prison sentences,
I don't really think they care, Bill, about
the rehabilitative effect or the the odds
of recidivism.
I think there's a sort of you did the thing
and now you deserve a strict punishment.
There's kind of this strict father morality
aspect to it that's totally untethered from
the actual impact.
What's your sense?
Speaker 5: That's absolutely right.
There are a couple of reasons why we should
care.
Even a lot of people have a hard sell on it.
There's a, I guess, moral reason that Americans
like to profess that we believe in second
chances and redemption.
And so if we want to live up to those ideals,
we should be.
Treating them as if they were redeemable.
But beyond that, there's a pragmatic, down
to earth, self centered argument for rehabilitation.
Every year we let out 600,000 people from
state and federal prisons.
Would you rather have those people emerge
from prison, brutalized, alienated, stigmatized
and lacking in any kind of skills that will
help them reenter the real world?
Or would you like to have them equipped with
citizens and neighbors?
I'd made a pretty convincing argument.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it seems the preferable answer
is clear on that.
To talk a little bit about the kind of society
that is created within many prisons, you know,
I, I interviewed the author, Ted Conover,
who wrote this book, New Jack, in which he
actually became a great book.
He became a corrections officer at Sing Sing
in New York and talks about his experiences.
And he did it knowing his plan was ultimately
to write a book.
And he talks quite a bit about the reality
of the sort of culture around being a corrections
officer in the United States and the pressures
faced systemic and and otherwise.
And he doesn't excuse any of the behavior
that he observed when he was in the job, but
he sort of gives a glimpse into the realities
of how the corrections officers circumstances
impact how prisons are run as well.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
What is unique in the United States about
being a corrections officer and the expectations
and the pressures?
Speaker 5: If you want to be a corrections
officer in Germany, you have to take two years
of college level courses, including things
like human rights, law, psychology, sociology.
And then you're.
Your job is to be a therapist is putting it
a little too strongly, but to engage the inmates,
to try to figure out what it was that made
them go wrong and see what programs would
be able to address it.
If you're going to become a corrections officer
in the United States, and I'm generalizing
broadly here, there's a saying in corrections
that you've seen one prison.
You've seen one prison.
Everyone has its own kind of culture.
Yeah.
But for the most part, you're going to become
a corrections officer, as Ted Conover's book
demonstrated.
You're going to get a few weeks of training,
mostly about crowd control and self-defense.
It's it's a it's more of a paramilitary organization.
It's I have as Ted emerged from that experience
with a fair amount of empathy for the prison
guards, that they're, in a sense, victims
of the environment and the culture, too.
And I think there's some truth in that.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And it seems to some degree.
Oh, sorry, Bill.
I was going to say there seems to be a mirroring
in one of the things that it seems many police
departments would benefit from mirrors something
that corrections officers would benefit from
as well, which is more training along the
lines of of sort of social work and relationship
building and community building.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
And you can find leaders.
Speaker 5: Of organized corrections officers,
unions and things who will say that it's.
In the last ten years or so, they've begun
to talk the talk a little bit.
Unfortunately, they're organized and in the
states that have really strong corrections
officers, unions, they tend to be a source
of resistance because that's.
Speaker 1: One of the things that is more
unique in the United States is this concept
of a for profit prison run by a corporation
that contracts with various agencies.
And sometimes those contracts include a guaranteed
occupancy where even if there is not actually
a certain occupancy, the prison operator gets
paid as if they were.
So they have a certain expectation of guaranteed
revenue that they are going to be receiving.
Can you talk a little bit about even though
most inmates in the United States are not
held at for profit private prisons, what is
particular or unique to the for profit prison
experience in the United States?
Or is it the same as in these state run and
federal prisons?
Speaker 5: You know, there's another book
by a journalist who went undercover as a prison
guard to Shane Bauer's book.
He went underground in a Louisiana prison
that was a private by Corrections Corporation
of America.
And he he does a nice job, first of all, of
demonstrating that the bottom line becomes
a big factor in the thinking of those prisons.
But also the whole history of incarceration
in America.
It has various profit motives associated with
starting those and most egregiously, with
the South, where prison labor became a substitute
for slave labor.
Hmm.
With much improvement in the conditions and
certainly without any pay.
Speaker 1: So it seems as though it's essentially
quite similar, but with the profit motive
added on top of it.
I mean, is that fair to say?
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's that's I think that's
fair to say.
It's actually you're right in saying that
it's a small percentage of the incarcerated
population who are in privately run prisons,
but that misses auxiliary services, that even
the state run prisons contract for people
to make available to to do medical care, to
do transport, to run the cafeterias.
Often those are contracted out to private.
Companies that don't have any incentive to
do.
Speaker 3: More than they have to.
Speaker 1: Also, there's elements of privatization
even within state and federally run prisons
as well.
I did not know that.
Speaker 3: Well.
Speaker 5: One example that's been a big issue
lately in a lot of prisons is there's a company
that makes available tablets so that you can
download books for your class and communicate.
As a general rule, prisoners don't have access
to the Internet, but they can get limited
services on a tablet.
But the company charges exorbitant rates for
the.
The use of the.
Rarely have any opportunity to earn the money
to pay for them.
Speaker 1: Yup.
And that we've seen that also with the with
exorbitant phone rates in prisons as well.
Bill, we've been speaking with Bill Keller,
who is the author of What's Prison for Punishment
and Rehabilitation in the Age of Mass Incarceration.
Bill, very interesting and I really appreciate
your time today.
Speaker 5: Well, thanks for having me on.
I'm glad to spread the message.